tenemos aquí una recta numérica con tres
números el número y el número c y el
número b y por aquí tenemos cuatro
desigualdades y lo que queremos ver es
cuáles de estas desigualdades son
ciertas y cuáles son falsas
entonces como siempre te recomiendo que
le pongas pausa el vídeo y lo intentes
por tu cuenta
ok vamos a ver esta desigualdad de aquí
nos estamos preguntando si a es menor
que ve a esta por aquí que está por aquí
podemos ver claramente que a está a la
izquierda de b y eso lo que nos dice es
que así es menor que b entonces esta
desigualdad está muy bien bueno y además
a es un número negativo y b es un número
positivo porque está a la izquierda de 0
y b está a la derecha de 0 y cualquier
número que sea negativo siempre va a ser
menor que cualquier número positivo pero
bueno más fácil que eso
el hecho de que a esta a la izquierda
debe en la recta numérica y por la forma
en la que construimos esta recta
numérica siempre vamos creciendo hacia
la derecha entonces el número de la
izquierda siempre va a ser menor que el
número de la derecha pero bueno ahora
vamos con la siguiente desigualdad esta
desigualdad dice que el valor absoluto
de a es mayor que el valor absoluto debe
ser a eso cierto pues a ver veamos dónde
está el valor absoluto de a tenemos que
a está por aquí y está a tres marcas del
cero entonces el valor absoluto va a
estar a tres marcas del cero pero del
lado positivo siempre del lado positivo
pero con la misma cantidad de marcas de
distancia ok entonces nos vamos tres
marcas a la derecha
justo aquí entonces el valor absoluto de
a se encuentra justo aquí en el mismo
lugar que se han querido si a esta a
tres marcas de distancia del cero
entonces el valor absoluto de a también
va a estar a tres marcas de distancia
del cero pero siempre del lado positivo
siempre del lado derecho aunque entonces
aquí están las tres marcas de distancia
justo en el punto de cee y bueno también
lo podemos pensar como que el valor
absoluto está midiendo la distancia de a
al cero pero bueno será el valor
absoluto de a mayor que el valor
absoluto debe pues lo que tenemos que
hacer es ver dónde se encuentra el valor
absoluto breve aunque y para eso veamos
a ver ve está a 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 marcas a
la derecha del 0 entonces el valor
absoluto de b va a estar también a 8
marcas de vista
del 0 y del lado positivo del lado
derecho va a estar también en la marca 8
a la derecha del 0 quiere va a estar
justo aquí también éste también es el
valor absoluto de b y esto concuerda con
lo que hemos visto acerca del valor
absoluto cierto porque el valor absoluto
de números positivos es ese mismo número
y también tenemos que el valor absoluto
de números negativos es el opuesto de
ese número y el valor absoluto de 0 se
queda ahí mismo en el 0 pero bueno el
valor absoluto de a es más grande que el
valor absoluto de b
pues no porque el valor absoluto de a
está a la izquierda del valor absoluto
de b y entonces es más chico así es que
esta desigualdad está mal vamos con la
siguiente desigualdad que queremos saber
si el valor absoluto de a es menor que
el valor absoluto de c el valor absoluto
y ya lo tenemos por aquí y acerca del
valor absoluto de ese fuese está a la
derecha del cero o sea que es un número
positivo y entonces el valor absoluto de
c es igual a c así es que se encuentra
también en este mismo punto aunque éste
también es el valor absoluto versión y
lo que estamos observando aquí es que el
valor absoluto de a es igual al valor
absoluto de c también y como son iguales
entonces no puede ser menor así es que
esta desigualdad también está mal si
aquí en lugar de tener un menor
tuviéramos por ejemplo que el valor
absoluto de a fuera igual al valor
absoluto de c entonces esta desigualdad
bueno esta igualdad estaría bien pero
pues esa no es la desigualdad que nos
estaban preguntando
bueno vamos con la última desigualdad
que nos dice a menor que se y otra vez a
esta aquí se está aquí la a está a la
izquierda de ese entonces a si es menor
que se aunque porque estamos en una
recta numérica y las rectas numéricas
crecen de izquierda a derecha y entonces
un número es menor que cualquier número
que se encuentre a la derecha de ese
número así es que esta desigualdad es
cierta y listo terminamos